hi there steve here
steve kaufman and today i want to begin
by making a confession
i am a serial language learner
cereal
implies maybe not serious i try or have
tried to learn a lot of languages and
the reason i'm making this confession
and you know i just had a look here
without trying very hard i have these
books on learning check i haven't really
looked at this assimil for check because
i have other materials that i have used
i do intend to get into turkish but
again i'm waiting we do now have mini
stories in turkish
on links so i'm going to get a turkish i
bought a
some material on croatian we don't have
croatian at link
uh and lots of others and so
i'm a bit of a dilettante and and this
kind of came home to me oh before i get
any further i should show you my t-shirt
because august the 21st to the 26th in
montreal
is the long fest i encourage you to come
it's a lot of fun you learn stuff and
you just have a wonderful wonderful
however many days four or five days look
it up on the you can google for it
l-a-n-g-f-e-s-t
long fest and uh somewhere there's a
website hope to see you there
so
uh the reason i'm talking about my
tendency to uh you know
dabble in a lot of languages
is that uh on my last in my last video i
finished off speaking in russian and
ukrainian with alexander
and so there were mixed comments about
my
levels in these languages
and of course i haven't really been
spending any time on them over the last
say year or so
uh and there were lots of mistakes and
someone said you know
uh
your russian brings uh
makes my blood boil or words to that
effect
you know you don't seem to realize that
there are cases in russian do you even
know what a genitive case is and stuff
like that
which is a bit surprising because people
may criticize but not with that kind of
a tone then it turns out that this guy
was an englishman which explains it not
because he's an englishman but because
he's a non-native speaker so people who
have achieved
a high level in a particular language
seem to want to point out
shortcomings in other people's use of
that language it's not something that i
like to do
but that's you know part of it
however it makes me realize that that in
language learning if you pursue quantity
like i'm doing now
uh
it's difficult to maintain quality
because as i've said many times language
learning is a function of your attitude
and the time you spend
so if you spend time on language
b c d e
then you can't spend that time on
language a
and in all of my languages i could
improve
even my best language which is french
there was a period about four or five
years ago when i listened to a lot of
french audiobooks french literature
and
that brought the level of my french up
to a higher level than ever before even
though i studied in france for three
years i wrote all my exams in french i
was totally submerged in a french
environment
these few years ago when i devoted
myself to listening to french literature
in audiobooks it elevated the level of
my french and i know that i could do the
same with my japanese
my ability to understand literature in
japanese is not great i have
shortcomings in vocabulary there
i could greatly improve my japanese if i
devoted the time to it the same is true
of my chinese i'm so aware of areas that
i would like to work on in chinese
my spanish and so forth
so necessarily i have let's say my top
five languages the languages that i
mentioned just now i'm confident that i
don't make a lot of mistakes
when i move into swedish german italian
portuguese cantonese russian there's
going to be more and more and more
mistakes
now why don't i then devote myself to
improving in those languages rather than
exploring new languages good question
however
when i think of the enjoyment that i
derive
from knowing ukrainian and and even
polish now i had a chat in polish and i
spent a bit more time with polish and
czech and slovak which are slightly
different
it's fun
and then i thought to myself you know
and i'm working on my arabic
but then i said geez i'm kind of losing
my
romanian and greek so the last two days
while doing dishes and working around
the house i've been listening to our
greek many stories and just now i was on
the treadmill working out and i was
doing reading
some of the greek many stories and then
just for fun i switched to romanian and
so i was doing the same thing in
romanian and it's a wonderful feeling
because you go back to an old friend
you realize at first that you have
you know
slipped quite a bit
but very quickly it comes back this is
my experience
and you have the feeling that with a
little bit of effort you could bring it
past where it was before which gets back
to something i've talked about before
uh the sort of cognitive research which
shows that things that we forget
leave for a while and come back to and
learn again we end up learning them
better so for all of these reasons
having plowed forward in some of these
newer language languages
doesn't mean that i can't go back later
and work on some of my better languages
to improve them if i want
some of the languages that i have the
least good grasp on like the greek and
the romanian i can at any time go back
to
and in the meantime i'm exploring
arabic and eventually i'll take arabic
to a level where for example once we get
farsi at link
and uh apparently we're quite close to
getting 50 mini stories i'm going to go
and do some farsi because there are more
opportunities to use farsi here in north
vancouver than uh or in west north
vancouver then is the case with arabic
which doesn't mean i won't go back to
arabic again i'll just continue
exploring and i also want to do turkish
because in in my mind turkish arabic
farsi that's kind of that middle east
central asian part of the world that i
want to get a better feel for
but
also in terms of language exploration
because i love our many stories i think
they're a fabulous way
to learn languages because
again something that i've said before
the brain likes novelty but the brain
likes repetition or put another way the
brain likes things that are familiar
so if you have 60 stories that are
essentially the same in all languages
you have in a familiar environment so it
becomes almost like me getting on the
treadmill it's the same treadmill every
day i'm not going anywhere but i'm
training so you can go into these many
stories whether you are a beginner or
whether you're going back to refresh
they're always there it's a comfortable
familiar environment and you can even go
into languages that you haven't studied
for example my romanian stories we
didn't have the many stories when i was
doing romanian i get in there and i'm
totally at home in the romanian many
stories
picking up words that i'd forgotten
and i went into dutch and danish many
stories and because i'm familiar with
the stories themselves plus my knowledge
of swedish and german and so what very
quickly you know i have the feeling that
if i were to devote any time to these
languages
then i could i could you know
get a certain level in them i have to
admit that when i listen to a danish
movie i struggle to understand what
they're saying
uh even though it's very it's quite
similar to swedish
even more so is the case with with dutch
obviously but i think with a little
effort with these mini stories i could
at least get to where i could understand
movies so all of this exploration is fun
so the dilemma is am i willing to
sacrifice this exploration
in order to try to achieve a higher
level of perfection in some of the
languages that i already know
you know better
that's just the dilemma uh you know it's
it's like going to a banquet and trying
to figure out whether you want to eat
you know
the fish
or the steak i mean both are good
uh so it depends on your mood uh you
know and and certainly i felt that i was
you know the arabic is difficult so it's
a chore
and for me it was a real treat to be
able to go back into the greek and the
romanian
and but i am going to forge forward with
the arabic so i confess that i am a
serial language learner
i am nevertheless a serious language
learner
and to quote uh cat olam she said that
language is one of the few things that's
worth learning even
poorly
so
if you want to perfect your level in
language a and stay there that's fine
that's great if you want to explore
languages i guess the extreme example is
our friend moses mccormick
that's fine
uh it's it's there you know something
that that we can enjoy and speaking of
enjoying languages i remind you once
again please come to montreal
in august 21st 21st to 26th for the long
fest
and tomorrow my wife and i are driving
into the interior to soyuz
uh where we're going to be golfing with
friends these are friends that every
year we go out golfing
with so unfortunately i won't be able to
do any my wife doesn't like it when we
sit in the car and i listen to
arabic or some language he doesn't want
me to put arabic on in the car
and she even doesn't like it that that
you know i'm listening and not talking
to her i don't know why you know it's
quite unreasonable so for that reason
it'll be five hours in the car and a lot
of golf
so but there's so many things to enjoy
um i'll take a bit of a break from uh
languages and but i will try to make a
video when we're up there
hopefully the weather will be nice
thank you bye for now
[Music]
you